pas plus qu'on est dans l'amour avant
d'enchaîner avec les mariages et oui
directement pour ce thème spécial
couples on va enchaîner avec des
mariages avec des demandes à ce spécial
vous allez voir way we were pourri en
fait
[Musique]
breaking news la petite sirène dire
d'être demandée en mariage voici en
exclusivité les images
[Musique]
en sortant de l'avion cette somme a dû
se dire qu'il y avait de plus en plus de
mendiants dans l'enceinte de l'aéroport
mais très vite elle s'est aperçue que
ses hommes ne voulaient pas son argent
mais qu'un homme voulait simplement sa
main
[Musique]
n'est pas tout
la star
[Musique]
après six longs mois
oui
oh
ce monsieur est très prudent même si lui
et sa petite amie sont protégés ils
préfèrent la demander en mariage avant
de s'envoyer en l'air
voilà malgré les tenues de chef de
chantier c'est un très bon moment alors
que ce joueur prétend s'être blessé en
bois match de basket il est en fait en
train de préparer une belle surprise à
sa copine elle aussi présente sur le
terrain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah
mais quand on parle de demandes en
mariage grandiose la première la seule
l'unique qui nous vient en tête c'est
bien sûr la demande en mariage de gilles
verdez à fatou a tôt à chérie je t'aime
d'un amour inaltérable fatou je t'aime à
la folie alors fatou je te le demande
avec énormément d'amour et tant d'ardeur
ma chérie mon amour est ce que tu veux
m'épouser
il faut bien
[Applaudissements]
à
le mariage alors moi les demandes en
mariage
elles se sont alors j'ai fait des bonnes
demande en mariage mais pas forcément de
bon mariage sinon les demandes en
divorce
alors ça c'est alors oh là là c'est moi
qui les ai reçus donc ça se passe sur
les quatre mariages n'a pas un que tu as
fait de manière originale tout cas
demandé d'odeurs elles ont nettement non
non j'ai pas besoin de je suis déjà moi
même dit moi je je je reviens sur cette
demande en mariage mariage qu'on
attendait en chair de poule quand je la
reçois risque à ses larmes aussi gta
j'ai bossé bout ouais ouais ouais mais
par contre j'ai pas su le faire part
parce que vous n'êtes pas invité chez
voilà alors sur le plateau dont michel a
été mariée oui bien trempé et une
demande en mariage normal
ah oui c'était à l'époque dans les
années 90 des gants beurre frais voilà
allez voir le père de railler abensur
adi saba j'ai fait ça me façon 40 18
allez voir le père avec des bas ça se
faisait dans les bonnes familles excuse
moi tu fais du ruisseau de plus oui j'ai
été mariée divorcée depuis mais mon ex
mari c'est mon pote à la pompe est mon
meilleur ami de la vie il reste
quelqu'un qui est marié change la donne
alors il ya daniel n'est pas marié il
n'a jamais été marié et n'avait veut se
marier
en tout cas c'est vrai que je trouve ça
super émouvant quand tu vois quoi je
savais qu'un jour j'espère qu'un maximum
avant de demander en mariage aux
attentes qui couche avec rien j'ai dû
sonoriser une cinquantaine de mariage
avec oi sonoriser une cinquantaine
mariage c'est pire que les mariages dont
la soirée dansante commence à 5 heures
du matin samedi conseillers tous les
mariés débuté et us après l'entrée le
plat conseil d'ami quand vous avez rien
demandé
on était tranquille sur les demandes en
mariage il vous de mariée je suis marié
à cuba à la havane dans une belle
cadillac américaine en jetant des fleurs
blanches comme ça c'est anissi sur
isabelle elle a connu la démontrons
leurs frais elle était autre forme
il a oublié un mariage que ma mère lui
rappellent régulièrement donc elle a
considéré que c'était déjà fait et on a
oublié de se jurer fidélité et tous à
l'église tonnes ont été saisies de fous
rires un moment donné on a tout oublié
c'était dans un concert en fait il
fallait aimer beaucoup de sens et reds
était très très fort et m'a fait ma
demande en mariage et comme aujourd'hui
on n'est rien j'ai des demandes en
mariage
supplie aucune surprise aucun truc se
demande en mariage est ou non mais moi
j'étais traumatisé par un mariage où
j'ai assisté enfants avec mes parents
le gars n'est pas venu l'assise est la
leur je vous jure traumatisés dans les
films cités martin et jean françois je
suis connu ça nous on voit pas c'est
trop cher dépenser de l'argent
j'ai une petite boulette sur le mariage
attendez qu'est ce que c'est est ce que
c'est
ou c'est qu'il est encore tôt mais tout
à fait correct ça se passe en irlande il
ya là la femme bien avec son son futur
marié à la mairie et il est complètement
bourré voilà donc à cérémonie du coup ne
peut pas se faire
et le maire de lui dit écoute je veux
bien faire tous les efforts ça fait 10
fois vous venez à chaque fois est
complètement femmes furent marie
complètement bo venait quand ils agen
rien ah ben oui mais quand il a jailli
veut pas venir
[Musique]
allez pas mal